今日はドクターはじめな今日は私の研究中のお呼びしています
どうぞ
宜しくお願いしますそれじゃあ今日か元気ですする表よろしくお願いします
お久しぶりですよねーという今日はドクターはじめ
わー
元気平成に頼る
あーあ僕はの世界の実験のは何でもできますので
ありがとうございいただければどぅシリーズっていう盛況なんですけども僕やりたい
ことがありまして
じっとちっとはい n n n 2 n 2です何でしょ
オールといいますかそうですねえこーろせってことでしょうねやってますね中途半端で
最後まで
5ラグすっかりなかった医療になくちゃなかなか変わらない
4なるほどねそれで今日ですね言うと私の周りの人たちのお昼ご飯通の食べローの桜の
液体窒素で凍ら経てあげたいです
あ一瞬で凍らせてカチカチにするとそうでそうですいうことですか
できますかはいはい
感じですよろしくお願いします
なんか
先生の白衣かっこいいですねあっあの普通は時のはくじゃないんですけど
またすごいあのアニメとかで結果間にあるんですけどちょっとないのでちょっと作って
みてオリジナルのを作ったんですよ
いやもちろんですよまじつか入ってるドクターはじめのために持って来ませんこちら
プレゼントさせていただきますかえっ手が込んでいる
いろいろ考えて作った白衣です動いいいねはいどうぞ
出生地ません
某わー
なんかさっきのテロンテロンの白衣と違ってしっかりしてますねもうこれして来ません
ちかもこれ
ipad がここに入るサイズまじですかないほど違わにも入る
こっち側にも ipad ファイル4はや ipad を持ちができればたっこなく
なるそんなにがないですよ
まっすぐちっそれっ遊んでいきましょう
これが液体窒素入った b ですねからちょっとガラスの容器に注ぎまあああああ
結構がっつり
まあ
いい顔してますねせ税あ本当ですかやっぱり実験楽しい座ってなかったですヤ90号
[音楽]
がちょっとどのぐらいか音がかかっていますねまぁちょっとねあの
少し節約したのでね毎日は90ですけど約毎日200度くらいの液体なんなもう
ちょっとこれを動いてくれるような
paige
入れます
[音楽]
今の跳ねるビニールのボールを冷やすとあ月に見たい油そうですね
dust
持った
yeah
ana
あっはい1いいね a
しました hey それだけ別れちゃったーーーー
ボールか時間になって大爆発するんですねーなー今日級で凍るんがぁ
そうですねえお弁当も一瞬でこうと思いますね扱いぜひ宜しくお願いします
おまんパファーがマズメシ壁 c なんか変なんはな一世二回じゃないんだよほんと
いい
3倍です3ちょっと結構当たっていただきます
いただきまーす
またぞ俺の1面で軍4ゆっくりそんなもんとなった
2日まーすっ
甘酢らしい
あ
はい
あなた撮影残りあるしてるんです
失敗ん
いた大丈夫か大丈夫かいっっ
すぐ終わり投票すぐを強化
[音楽]
マッハ
あーんセンターゲットこちらですこれですか入っ
こうもても突破
[拍手]
ます入っ
[音楽]
ぜひますできました
ua 相次ぐ4できますはいありましょう
[音楽]
me
きゅっきゅ煙が風景
おっ
a
[音楽]
したというんだよ
だったん
こうての素復興
今まん
ねっフォークが浮いてる
はぁっ
おいおいの聞いて安くなぁ
お疲れたオリーブオイルうんはいですかお告げにどうぞ
嫁祝意を示しマーカーん俺やそしてですの道津岡養うこと
ね何本当に頭にあった場ができたのですね
またんですかどうぞそう
大森デミグラスソースのミートパサーよし加えてね
あってさ
普通にパッタくるだけですよねこれはジャアアアアーーーーーーッッッ
勝手に動くやって
を
[音楽]
怖いっ
教育なんか取り直し取り残しあるエスポワール
はいすぐ終わります
調査は彼に関してかと思っ
言われマイです
その呼ばれます
やばいやばいんこ
[音楽]
これ
手で今日だけたことですこちらですねっ入っちゃいましょう
俺の陸橋世代かけ
鼓動ずっといいすねあとは手を動かさないでいっぱいだして取ればやっぱり
いますしています
言うとどうなりたいかもっ
me
ぽって
木日
ねぇもうやっすごいけどそれ以上に手ブレもすごい
ああいやずん子もうやばいっ
はっ端にですねこれで行ったことは初めて合コンたくさん始めていますねー
あとはない
衆院じゃな受ける
あるねえ
何人かおります
まずないん
0えっ
[音楽]
防衛
ぽい子がやるなぁねぇ
持っています
妙善シャベル食べちゃうぞ
[音楽]
しています
voodoo
[音楽]